ownership is shifting and thinking about
all the little things we're seeing
companies like masterworks where you do
it with art we're seeing companies like
here where you can do it with short-term
rental properties or picasa like you can
do it with um long-term rental
properties but historically these are
things where you have to have millions
of dollars to invest in now you can have
a hundred dollars or ten thousand
dollars and get a piece of it instead of
having to own the full thing
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact
leap
google for startups and hippo and in
media partnership with
c-tech welcome to another episode of 20
minute leaders i'm excited to talk to
drew glover founding partner of fiat
growth and general partner at the
adventures about fintech and where we're
at today he is no stranger to the world
of growth technology and marketing from
his time at steady where he led
marketplace development and growth to
namely fjord and portal a he navigated
the ins and outs of go to market
strategies and user acquisition meet
drew
drew glover welcome to 20 minute leaders
i'm so excited to talk to you about the
growth the adventures fintech and
everything in between thank you very
much for being here
of course thank you so much for having
me michael
you know fintech space um growing uh
like crazy so many different things to
tackle so many different elements that
we're trying to change in the way that
we're thinking about finances whether
it's financial literacy the way we
manage our daily finances the gig
economy versus the the you know the
traditional economy and different
solutions from centralization to
decentralization i can't even wrap my
head around all the different things
that we have today to work on and so i'm
excited to pick your brain a little bit
in these 20 minutes about where your
passion lies and how you see how you see
this domain but but starting from from
your work with fiat growth and now fiat
ventures i'd love to hear a little bit
about your journey and and your your
world into fintech
yeah most definitely um
so yeah fiat growth was founded a little
over four and a half years ago by myself
and my co-founder alex harris fiat
growth is uh
the
industry-leading growth consultancy for
early stage and late stage fintech
companies where we
help them scale we are the strategy and
the execution around building the pipes
and the foundation around all things um
growth and performance marketing
so around four years ago alex and myself
we started fiat growth we'd known each
other for 20 years we both went to uc
berkeley together
funny story i actually played football
there and he was an equipment manager
there and we just like became like best
friends and so fast forward many years
later he was working at chime um he at
the very large neobank and he was head
of growth in partnerships there i was
head of growth in partnerships at steady
which helps folks in the 1099 world
improve their financial health and we
started co-advising a number of
companies together and what we quickly
realized is that so many especially
fintech companies because they have such
complex funnels like the trust and like
what you need to be able to pull out of
a customer
for them not only to sign up for a bank
but to ultimately open up an account and
fund that account it's a very complex
process and involves a lot of
great expertise
so we started
we quit our day jobs we founded fiat
growth and had a fairly unique model
where we would not only get a retainer
for our services but we'd also ask for
advisory shares and we'd get equity or
we'd ask for the right to invest in
every company we worked with that
quickly scaled up um today we have 25
full-time employees
and um we basically oversee all
partnerships and influencer marketing on
one side of the business and then the
other side of the business is all
performance marketing so that's building
out your martech stack it's funnel
optimization it's owning all your
different paid channels but what was
really exciting is
over time that right to invest that we
got with all of our contracts gave us
the ability and the option to invest in
any company that we were working with
hands-on that we thought were going to
be outsized winners in the space and it
gave us the ability to choose if we
wanted to invest in them or not so
in 2021
we raised a 15 million dollar venture
fund and uh which gave us the ability
and the flexibility to kind of pick and
choose the companies that we already
worked with on the fiat growth side the
consultancy
of which ones we wanted to invest in so
taking a quick step back there fiat
growth is not only this incredible
growth consultancy where we are like the
full strategists and executors of all
things growth think of us as a turnkey
or outsourced cmo um but it also doubles
as one of the best due diligence arm
arms in the business because we're able
to work with the companies prior to
investment which is really hard to do an
early stage venture and on the venture
fund we get to invest in them so we're
typically investing in pre-seed to call
it series a companies um typically
trying to get like a small percentage of
the business but the really exciting
part is is um we just have this
unprecedented access to venture
especially in the early stage that the
the traditional vc doesn't because we
get to work with the client prior to
investment so we understand the founders
the the product the innovation behind it
if they can scale if the users love the
product or not and then we can make a
decision if we actually want to deploy
capital and invest into them
fantastic so so many more data points
much more intentionality behind
obviously those early those early
investments and since they're all about
the team
you get to actually experience the team
in a very beautiful way before before
deploying the capital
tell me about the focus on fintech as a
decision point for you
yeah so
a lot of it came organically when alex
and myself were at at previous fintechs
and we're we were working at consumer
fintech so chime has you know i don't
know somewhere between 10 million and 15
million users today the fastest growing
digital bank of all time and steady has
around five or six million users but
while we were building up those
communities we were really realizing
that
we're entering this golden age of
fintech it's the next evolution of
innovation within that space
historically
you know we all grew up with with banks
that had brick and mortar stores we all
remember being you know 13 or 14 or 15
walking in with their with your parent
opening up your first account and um
that kind of being this moment in our
lives where now
anyone can sign up for a bank account
digitally without having to go into a
brick-and-mortar service and therefore
by these companies being able to
save all this money
on the overhead of having to like
purchase real estate they can invest
that money back into the business so
what we just saw is that there was this
opportunity because we are holding these
phones in our hands on a day-to-day
basis to bring finding a brief financial
technology
into the hands of everyone and once the
the mobile revolution really hit its its
peak where literally everyone has a cell
phone and everyone has access to cell
phones everyone has access to internet
it became this opportunity to start
really thinking and innovating
innovating around what the future of
finance looks like that was really
interesting and compelling to alex and
myself at the time and obviously we're
incredibly proud in terms of us kind of
following that instinct because what fit
what fintech is today it's not only
redefining how our parents and our great
grandparents
and even us
knew of what fintech was call it 10 20
30 years ago but we're also on the
forefront of being able to see how
future generations look at fintech v g
high schoolers college college students
even
you know even the the five-year-old to
the 10 year old um but there's going to
be a new generation around the
relationship with finances and like
we're very much looking through that
window and it's looking really really
compelling
and so is this sort of a convergence on
where
where the big impact is today so you're
mentioning that we have this whole new
generation that's just managing finances
in a completely different way and so
there's a variety of solutions that need
to come into place but even there you
know we have a wide spectrum of
different solutions that may go in there
are you more excited about specific ones
specific verticals within this new
fintech world that you're particularly
you know convicted on that this is where
we should be today
yeah i mean i i could spend hours
talking about this but just to like
quickly name a few
um one is just the convergence of
fintech with uh with a lot of these
other industries that aren't
historically a fintech
partner for example um
uh the future of work and how people
work in in the near future here it's
continuing to shift we talk about the
proliferation of the gig economy like
uber and lyft we talk about the creator
economy where you know we're seeing like
seven year olds uh 18 year olds becoming
huge influencers online and making a lot
of money just based on creating content
but
the way we think about finance is now
where we we used to think about finances
is hey if you have money come here and
we'll help you open up a checking and
savings account right
where today if you're making money um
there's all these different ways that
you should be managing it and people
that are younger are making more money
now so it's really around how can we
bring together both
how you're earning money
based on the jobs you're having
connecting that with your bank and
giving you much more insight into your
words you said earlier financial
literacy so as you're earning money you
can also learn about money and you can
also learn how to set yourself up for
the future so again like i think the
future of work and how people work and
how that connects to your bank account's
huge i think the creator economy is huge
and that is changing how people are
managing their money and how they're
making money um also if you are a
creator and you're making money from
instagram or youtube you're technically
a 1099 worker you're not a w-2 worker
like we a lot of folks know today where
they automatically take out your taxes
you know and they are
you know they're basically taking care
of all the kind of like governmental
engagement around work but when you're a
1099 worker it's a huge shift which
brings me to another kind of vertical
here which is just the freelancer
economy in general people are changing
the way they're working where it's no
longer i have one source of income
therefore i have one way i need to
manage it but the future of work is a
lot of people having multiple different
forms of income that ultimately create a
full-time salary
other things that are jumping out there
is obviously obviously the web 3 world
investments uh retail investments like
robin hood coinbase we talk about all
the things that we're seeing in crypto
and we're only seeing people that are
super young really taking a risk on that
those are like the early adopters to
investment and us playing a role through
fintech to help teach these individuals
how to do that in a responsible way and
also making it so they're thinking about
it you know 20 30 years out and they're
not trying to become you know young day
traders but there's a huge financial
literacy gap that we can really play a
role in there 100 and so one of the
other big shifts that we've we've had is
this idea that if before we had and you
mentioned this before we had a few
institutions that were able to to deal
with capital or to provide some
you know some mechanism for managing
finances in all its forms today we have
so many different companies doing this
from early stage startups to to growth
startups and so many many more offerings
how is that changing you know the market
perspective on fintech now that you know
we have so many different players that
maybe are fighting for those same
eyeballs fighting for that same customer
behavior
are there different understandings of
who may come on top or what or you know
how the market is going to react to such
a decentralization of of of services
yeah it's a really good question it's
one i thought a lot about
what we're going like what we used to
see is we have these like monopolies and
duopolies in the in the market where
what we're starting to see is
affinity-based fintech
job or a company creation or affinity
banking when i say affinity
these are individual companies that
instead of building products for the
entire universe or all of america
they're building products for very very
specific communities you know for
example you might build a neo-bank just
for the african-american community or
you know we just invested in a company
called copper which is a bank for teens
again a teen is a very specific type of
community which is a it's it's an
affinity relationship you're building a
bank built for the african american
community it's an affinity of a
community also there's another company
we worked with called daylight which is
doing it for the lgbtq community as well
so what we're seeing here is these like
very very targeted focused
businesses built around a specific
community that needs a very very
specific type of um financial
relationship and way of banking and so
just specifically i'll tell you this you
know you're mentioning communities and
targeted is that mainly from a
understanding that there's different
consumer behaviors amongst different
communities different spending habits
different
you know different solutions that need
to be tailored or is it more of a
from a marketing perspective let's let
well we'll be better off if we sort of
position ourselves with this niche
because then we'll gain better trust
because finances is all about trust
yeah so i actually say those go hand in
hand okay um for example um
the way uh
you know call it a lower to middle
income african-american uh you know
25 something um engages with marketing
is very different than if you were like
you know uh just called bank of america
that's just trying to market to the
entire country as a whole so from a
marketing standpoint yes you can be a
lot more strategic and a lot more
targeted but from a product standpoint
now obviously product and marketing go
hand in hand yes these are two
completely different lifestyles um for
example with daylight the lgbtq bank um
you know there's a lot of people going
through transition um from um you know
they're going to a trend a transgender
transition and history and also what
that means is your name is actually
changing as well legally so historically
if you were to walk into some of these
some of the banks that we we grew up on
they wouldn't recognize your name change
and even a gender shift as well and so
that's like a very very it's a very
important piece to the lgbtq community
but not something that some of these
traditional banks would even recognize
or a very like rudimentary example for
um you know a bank built for the
african-american community
i get a haircut
twice a week like that is something that
is ingrained in black culture like we
get haircuts like that is something that
we all do like if we have a cash back
card with that bank i should be getting
cash back based on me getting haircuts
not necessarily me you know doing
something different so like these are
like very like small things to some
people but within this like world of
affinity fintechs it becomes like really
it's a huge opportunity to build a deep
relationship based on how these people
spend money and they're very unique very
specific lifestyles so obviously there's
you know there's there's the more
trivial
it can store behaviors that we're that
we're converging to and we understand
that we need to
to tailor to and then we mentioned a few
of them here are there larger ideas that
you know if you're looking a few years
down the line a few gaps that are still
sort of not really tapped or people
aren't necessarily giving enough
attention to that would be worth looking
into when it comes to fantastic
generations or anything in between
yeah totally so
a couple things i'll keep going back to
this freelancer economy um
folks folks really are not focusing on
on the future of work enough
like that
the future of work especially in like
this next generation
of users that we see coming up
they see work different than our parents
saw
they want to have multiple different
jobs they want to have side gigs they
want to have
anywhere between like two and ten
different forms of income and this
creates such an opportunity to help them
better understand finances better
understand taxes and to better
understand like finance finance as a
whole as it pertains to america and even
across the universe um you know we were
lucky enough to see again the ubers and
the lips and the door dashes and all
these different delivery platforms but
literally anyone right now can get on
regardless if you make a hundred
thousand dollars a year or ten thousand
dollars a year and go sign up and start
delivering doordash and that is just a
different form of income so that's
that's one where i feel like there's so
many things we can solve there um
and then the other one is i i still
think there's just such a huge literacy
play
with um
with crypto um i believe that crypto is
here to stay yes it's been a really
tough market um but
we have all these folks especially
low-income communities um leading into
you know purchasing nfts purchasing
crypto purchasing all altcoins and um
and there should be a lot more focus on
making sure that folks understand that
market
instead of just treating it like a day
trading opportunity and um you know the
people that are most at risk here are
the people that have the least amount of
money and so it's a really really
important opportunity um from a literacy
standpoint and then the last thing i'll
say is just ownership um right now we're
seeing fractional ownership pop up a lot
where you can buy uh like a piece of
of a real estate property or a piece of
a of a share of amazon and so i think
ownership
the definition of ownership especially
like hard to to reach ownership things
like houses and other stuff along along
those lines it's significantly changing
so i feel like if people are looking to
like really get into the space
especially entrepreneurs like ownership
is shifting and thinking about all the
little things we're seeing companies
like masterworks where you do it with
art we're seeing companies like here
where you can do it with short-term
rental properties or picasa like you can
do it with um long-term rental
properties but historically these are
things where you have to have millions
of dollars to invest in now you can have
a hundred dollars or ten thousand
dollars and get a piece of it instead of
having to own the whole thing right so
and this is you know we're looking a few
years back fraction
you know fraction of shares from
companies style what robinhood did and
we're looking at so you're saying you
know we're going we're expected to see
this downstream effect where
a lot of these different assets that
previously we
you know in our mind we always consider
them as you know you have to have the
whole piece in order to be the owner of
it now
and obviously it's complicated because
it requires a lot of logistics right it
requires a lot of
a lot of maintenance of data integrity
and how do you
and all these different edge cases on
what happens when somebody doesn't
fulfill the requirement and which which
makes it difficult especially during the
the last the way that fintech was before
with the centralization of of who is who
can give you that ownership or that
financial service now now we're going to
be seeing a lot more solutions
and we're running out of time this is a
fascinating conversation but you know
what drew you to to this world so out of
all the different things that that you
that you could have done in the space
why why fintech and and why this
you know i grew up in east oakland out
here in california in in a low to middle
class neighborhood um
you know a couple blacks over a couple
blocks over it was fully
lower income you know where i was there
was like lower to middle income
and you know i grew up in neighborhoods
where
the majority of the folks i grew up
around just didn't have access
to
financial technology didn't understand
and have the opportunity to learn you
know how to best manage their money and
how to best grow their money and think
20 years out instead of you know a year
out and there's the
the the nationwide stat of 5 75 of
americans don't have 500 in savings in
case of emergency and so for me getting
into the spintec space was really around
working with and investing in companies
that are creating
access and lowering the barrier of
access to the folks that need help the
most
and so when i think when we think about
what the future of fintech is
yes it's we're we're talking about you
know the relationship with gen z and
like teens and college students and like
but at the end of the day here it's it's
really around making sure now that
everyone has a cell phone in their hand
that everyone has access to the internet
and in most cases it's free
we're providing
uh
i'm working with a lot of these
companies and investing in a lot of
these companies to make sure these are
the ones that are lowering the access
barrier for typically the people that
were forgotten in america which i i'd
call you know the 90 of america that
doesn't have um the means or might be
living living paycheck to paycheck but
there's such an opportunity with where
fintech is headed and the next
generation of fintech where from a
literacy standpoint from an innovation
standpoint like working with like uh
companies that are helping to build
folks credit so they don't get into you
know credit issues at an early age which
will impact how they're able to like
think about money at a later age but
building and and thinking about this
business and this world around lowering
the access barrier and making sure that
the 90 percent of america typically and
historically didn't have financial
products built for them are having those
products built for them now that could
help improve their overall for a
financial health and lifestyle
incredible i think it's a such an
interesting space right and i'm looking
forward to revisiting this conversation
a few years down the line looking back
at what we discussed and saying you know
what's happening and obviously in 20
minutes we can't dive
nearly deep enough but it's but it was
there don't worry any conversation so
drew thank you very very much
best of luck with fiat ventures i love
the model and it sounds like yeah you
also have a lot of fun doing what you're
doing which is the most important thing
thank you very much
thanks so much for the time michael i
appreciate it
you